hello everyone and welcome back for yet
another video I'm trying to crank these
out quickly before I head back to New
York for Christmas and New Year's and uh
yeah let's see if I do a decent job with
them even with the time constraints so
today we'll be doing type ahead
suggestions I can't lie that's not the
type of head I've been thinking about
the most recently but nonetheless it's
the one that we'll be talking about so
let's go ahead and get started and make
a nice video all righty so I believe
we've got 23 slides today so my guess on
the over under for the length of this
video is going to be 32 minutes let's
see how I do all right so for those of
you who are not too familiar with a type
ahead suggestion basically what I mean
when I say something like that it could
basically be two things so one is over
here on the left as you can see it's
like imagine you're texting and when you
actually text over here in your box you
can see that from that text input you've
actually got a couple of suggestions
coming up that are Autos suggested to
you from your keyboard so that would be
one example of it where it's like uh per
word type of head suggestions right so
for H L it's suggesting hell hello
Helena anything that basically H is a
prefix of and ideally the most popular
words uh that are suffixes of H so
another possibility would be something
like the Google search bar where for a
single term over here as you can see if
I'm typing Jordan has we can actually
suggest full Search terms and these as
opposed to being just one word could be
multiple words and much longer and as a
result there are probably many more
possibilities of terms that we could
potentially be suggesting so the examp
examples might be has no life you see
another couple that people tend to
search over here when it comes to me but
uh that's how it goes and so the
interesting thing about this problem is
I think at least for this piece over
here on the left uh it's an interesting
problem algorithmically maybe less so
from a systems design perspective I
actually think over on the right this
one gets a little bit more complex just
simply because when you have so many
more potential Search terms that you can
suggest it means that you're actually
going to have to partition your data put
it on multiple different servers and
then uh that's going to make the problem
more complicated as a result so we'll
discuss the nuances of that but at least
for now what we're going to do is start
by talking about how we can Implement
number one and then once we figure that
out we can actually scale it over to
number two and talk about how we can
Implement that in a distributed setting
so in order to really get into things
the first thing that we have to do is
talk about our problem requirements so
that we can actually formalize these out
a little bit the first one is going to
be that when we type in our text box
we're going to quickly load the top
suggestions so if it's the left problem
that's going to be the top three
suggestions if it's the right problem
it's going to be the top 10 uh but
hopefully that makes sense and then
additionally they can be either for
individual words if this is the auto
suggestion case or if it's the Google
search case full Search terms and then
finally we don't necessarily have to
update those top terms instantaneously
but they should be updated at least once
per day and we can talk about how we'll
do that in a little bit uh additionally
we're not going to deal with any
personalized suggestions for uh for now
you might see if you're typing in Google
search in real life that you know if
you've searched something in the past it
might actually come up first we're not
going to deal with that for the current
time so let's go ahead and talk about
some capacity estimates because the
really way that we can actually reason
about this problem is by getting a sense
of how much data we're actually dealing
with here so the main idea of this
problem is that we want to make the read
speeds as fast as possible right I
mentioned that we really only have to
update this top terms list once per day
and that means wres we don't really care
about the latency of too much but when
we're typing I really want to make sure
that I see these suggestions come up as
quick as possible otherwise this feature
isn't going to be that useful because I
type lots of keys pretty quickly so how
can we actually go ahead and make this
as fast as possible well if you think
about it if we're really thinking
naively here and we're not even thinking
from like a systems assigned standpoint
the fastest way of doing anything is to
just keep all the possibilities in
memory on that client device so that is
going to be the most ideal case scenario
and the question is based on the
capacity constraints can we actually do
this let's try and figure it out so here
is some crude math that I'm going to do
here and obviously this is just me doing
estimations that being said I'm trying
to calculate an upper bound here of how
much storage we would actually need and
as a result that way we know that you
know if the upper bound could
potentially fit on a client device then
the actual number probably could too so
here is my thinking for the actual type
of head suggestion case which as you can
remember is we suggest the top three
words given me punching in a few
different letters so here is my thinking
in English because uh I am an English
speaker at the end of the day so I'm
going to focus on that there are around
200,000 words I Googled that one the
average word length is 4.7 characters
which I'm going to go ahead and round to
five so that gives us about a million
words that we've got to store except
keep in mind that for each word we
actually want to store the result of all
the prefixes right because if I'm typing
out word this is a possibility that I
could potentially Auto suggest I need to
know the answers or basically the top
three suggestions for all possible uh
prefixes of that word so w I need to
have answers for wo I need to have
answers for w o r i need to have answers
for and w o r d I also need to have
answers for and so what that means is
that if each word is five characters on
average it means that there are
basically going to be five possible
prefixes that we need to store so
imagine we were storing some map right
where we have all of the possible
prefixes and then the three values that
are actually the most popular that we
need to store for that prefix well
basically this would mean that for
starters in our map there would be 1
million keys right because there are
five prefixes for each of the 200,000
words now keep in mind that in reality
some of these prefixes are going to be
the same so there are actually probably
less than a million entries but again
I'm trying to estimate an upper bound
here the next thing is that keep in mind
that if each word or each prefix is at
at most five characters that means that
we've got five bytes for the key itself
and then another 15 bytes for the
suggestions where do I get that from
well it's five bytes for each of the
three words that we have to store there
so in total that's a million * 20 bytes
and so as a result that is going to be
20 megabytes now 20 megabytes is
actually not a lot of memory even if
we're dealing with phones these days
most of them have in the gigabytes of
memory so I actually think that it's
decently feasible that we can store this
all in memory on our client device
even if for some reason we couldn't we
could somehow actually limit the amount
of storage that we were using right so
the previous calculation is going to
rely on the fact that we cach the final
results right so for example you know if
I type in the letter J I am caching the
fact that the top three suggestions
might be juice Jordan and uh join that
being said do we even have to do that
well what if we actually just stored the
number of counts of every single full
word and then basically anytime I typed
in a prefix we could on the Fly compute
uh what the top three words were so we
could do this and basically if we just
stored the count of each word keep in
mind that the count is an integer so
that's four
bytes and also there are 200,000 words
and so now we're basically just storing
the count of 200,000 Words which is
800,000 bytes which is 800 kilobytes and
that is definitely pretty feasible to
keep in memory on any of our client
devices and then so again the process
would be imagine we have some prefix X
then we would have to find all the top
three words that basically start with X
this is reg X right here so it's
basically saying words starting with
x now keep in mind that I mentioned a
pretty key thing which is that we want
to make our read speeds as fast as
possible right when I type in a prefix I
want to know those top three suggestions
as soon as humanly possible and the
problem with this one is that it's going
to involve computation right we're
regardless of how I actually sort my
words I'm still going to have to go
through some amount of them and actually
figure out what those top three
suggestions are and that's going to take
a little bit so ideally I do think that
we should just be caching that final
result but for the sake of doing a
little bit of uh fun data structures and
algorithms maybe we can actually go and
show that off in a little bit so let's
go ahead and continue our capacity
estimates in this time uh for the Google
search use so let's imagine now that
there are a bli unique search queries
per day I actually looked this up that's
actually about true in this case it
means basically in the mode where you
know we're just storing the counts of
each word right so this is going to be
the kind of like low memory way of doing
it that's still going to be four times a
billion queries and as a result that's 4
gbt we can't store 4 GB of memory on
every single client device a lot of them
might only have 4 GB total so we're
definitely not going to be doing that
and again this isn't even even going to
keep our read speeds that fast so
ideally we would like to preach all of
our answers so now let's imagine that
our average search term is 20 characters
right because these can be multiple
words it's you know I'm basically
guessing that each search term is four
words where each word is around five
characters I think that seems pretty
reasonable so if we have a billion of
these unique Search terms that come up
that are possibly autos suggestible and
basically we have to think about storing
the prefix of every single one of them
right because it's the same thing as
before where I broke word
into you know
W then
wo and on and on and on we would have to
do the same exact thing with that whole
search term but it's actually going to
have 20 prefixes this time because it's
much longer so that's going to give us a
map from basically prefix of a search
term to top 10 suggestions that's going
to have 20 billion entries now that's
obviously going to be quite a few
additionally if for each of those keys
we're going to have 10 different Search
terms and each search term is 20
characters and we have to store the
prefix in general that's going to be at
least around 200 bytes per entry of our
map and so now what we can do is
multiply those two values once we
multiply them out we can actually see
that in total that map to basically
store the top 10 suggestions for each
prefix of a given search term could be
at most 4 terabytes now that's obviously
a lot not only is that so much data that
we can't store it on client devices we
also could even store it on one server
assuming we wanted to keep our data in
memory which we might because we want to
keep our read speeds as fast as possible
so we're going to have to touch upon
this a little bit later in the video so
let's actually start talking about some
implementation details of you know how
once we have our data we can go ahead
and figure out what the top term is so
the first thing that I'm going to be
talking about is what I would call the
non-caching approach aka the low memory
approach that we discussed before
hopefully this should make the details a
little bit more concrete here so the
idea is recall that you know 20
megabytes is what we said our caching
approach would take so if we just want
to store the counts of every single word
we can do that and then figure out the
top three suggestions at least decently
fast and the nice thing about this is it
only requires less than a megabyte of
space at least using the assumptions
that I've made so let's imagine that we
store our data in the following way
basically we sort all the words by their
search order sort by key so this is
basically going to sort by the final
word that we might suggest and then we
have the counts over here on the
right and so the nice thing about this
is that you know for example if a user
were to type a we can basically query
for every single uh entry between A and
B right we're effectively doing a range
query here and so what we're doing now
is uh we're going to quickly binary
search find this end of it we're going
to binary search find this end of it and
then we're going to grab all of these
rows right here and now we know that we
just need to find the top three from
those rows so how can we actually
quickly find the top three well if
you're thinking back to your leite code
medium training what you should know is
that whenever you want to find the top n
suggestions on a list that's much bigger
than size n you should use something
like a Min heap of size you know n so
the gist here is we would use a Min heap
of size three so it's going to start out
where we would basically check arvar
first so three goes into the mid Heap
then we would check Andy six is going
into the M Heap but since this is a Min
Heap three is still going to stay at the
top right like if we popped a node
that's going to be the smallest one next
we check Apple and that's going to be 12
so it's still going in the Min Heap now
we've reached the biggest size possible
that our Min Heap is willing to support
such that when Arkansas comes in and as
you can see we've seen that one more
time than arvar it means that arar needs
to be removed from the Min Heap so what
we're going to do is pop three right
over here and then we're going to put
four into our Min Heap and since it's
the smallest element it is going to go
at the top of our Min Heap and it's
going to be the thing that we would peep
or remove next if there were a higher
element and so that is how we could
pretty easily find those top three
elements okay so that is what I'm going
to call the local non-caching approach
let's now actually start to think about
the local caching approach so the
problem with this guy was that you know
basically for every single turn it is
effectively a linear scan right because
I believe the complexity here is going
to be o of n but then you also multiply
in a factor of you know log of three
which is effectively constant so we
don't really care about this but the
point is it's linear to the number of
terms that are suffixed by your search
term right so linear to
possible uh suffix
terms and that's going to be pretty slow
especially if there are a lot of those
so what we would much rather do is say
you know say someone typed in a I would
much rather store somewhere on there
what the top three suggestions were and
have it pre-computed Apple Andy Arkansas
so that's kind of the idea we can just
keep a hashmap from our prefix to all of
its top suggestions and this is going to
allow us to basically get that in O of
one time which is really great but in
reality it's not exactly o of one right
because imagine that you know I was
searching for uh you know all of the top
suggestions from the term like a uh p p
so if I'm using a hash map I have to
actually go ahead and generate the hash
of
AP and keep in mind that AP isn't really
just like a single reference It's
actually an array of characters a
p p and for me to actually generate that
hash I have to iterate through that map
so in reality it's not actually o of one
here to find the top suggestions for a
given term but it's actually going to be
proportional to the length of the term
that you currently have typed in and so
the gist here is that it does take some
time to actually compute that hash
Computing the hash is O of one for every
single element of that character array
but we do have to iterate that array so
how could we improve upon this a little
bit more well if you recall when we
actually go and type in you know
AP the idea is this so we have a p p at
every single one of these elements we
need to find the top
suggestions top three and then now we
need to find them of AP top
three and then now we need to find them
again top three so if we could make each
of these individually o of
one o of one and O of
one it's actually going to be in
amortized time basically a constant time
to go and access the top suggestions
for this search term in combination
because we have to do all of that work
anyway so basically the gist is we want
to keep our reads as fast as possible we
want to keep our memory footprint as low
as possible what can we actually do so
this is where we start getting into
something called a try now again those
of you who are more lead Code season
veterans will probably already know
about this data structure but the gist
is it's just a tree except instead of
something like a binary search tree
where you can only have two children per
you can actually now have an arbitrary
number of children per node so how does
this actually help us out basically the
gist is we take every single phrase that
could possibly exist and then we would
go ahead and add it into our try right
so we would have a over here and then
imagine that you know we had all of
these deep words like Arkansas Apple
Andy and arvar now we actually have more
of the phrase in the next note and so
from a I can now go over to AP in O of
one time because from here to here is
literally just a pointer and so the gist
is at every single node we cach the top
terms and then let's imagine that you
know I was already making a search right
so I already got the top three terms for
this and then now all of a sudden I want
to get the top terms for AP so it's an O
of one jump down to AP and then I
already have access to the top terms
which is going to be really great so the
idea is that our try is going to allow
us to basically jump from uh one search
term to the other in O of one time
because we're only inputting one extra
character at a time so getting uh
getting suggestions for the next type
character is always going to be in
constant time which is really
great so another question is how much
memory does this actually use compared
to something like our hashmap approach
well for
starters keep in mind that uh over here
we're not basically duplicating every
single key now I actually kind of Drew
this out wrong a little bit because it
should look more like this b
o this should just have one
a this should have one
n this should have one p and this should
have one R so the idea is in our hash
map if you thought about it you know we
might have
apple uh we might have a we might have a
we might have a p p we might have a PPL
and the issue with that is that we have
all this extra storage and it's pretty
much redundant because it's all stored
in these letters of the term and if you
think about that that basically means
that to store all of the Search terms we
have to basically uh get quadratic in
the amount of memory that we're using
because of this little guy right here
that you might remember from some of
your math classes which is basically
saying that you know if you take a uh a
number and you go ahead and sum up all
of the numbers that are less than or
equal to that number then it's basically
like taking that number and squaring it
or it's got the same ASM totic
complexity of that and so to basically
store a given search term we're actually
quadratic in uh relation to the length
of that search term and so what we now
do instead by using a try is we actually
only have one path per search term right
this is eventually going to go all the
way down to Arkansas I didn't draw out
all the nodes cuz then the tree would
get very big but the idea is that now
we're only storing that search term once
and so now we're actually going to be
linear in relation to that search term
as opposed to quadratic that's going to
help us save some memory additionally
what if we were able to actually further
reduce the memory of The Returned values
there are a few ways that we can do this
one of them that I'm going to bring up
for now is something that we've spoken
about a little bit in the past called
dictionary compression so the idea
behind dictionary compression is that
certain terms are going to be repeated a
lot so if you notice here apple is a top
turn at node a it's also a top turn ter
at node P under a and so of course if we
have a term that's going to show up a
lot because it's super popular what we
could actually do is instead of
storing 5
bytes the idea behind dictionary
compression is to basically create a map
from let's say a short so if you know
what a short is that's basically a
number but it's two bytes so it's a
short to a
string and so we hold this hash map over
here and so instead of actually putting
Apple over here now I would say store it
as like 01 right so it's going to be the
first entry of the map so we would say
01 is mapped to
Apple and the idea behind the short is
now every single time we see a uh string
like that that's repeated a lot we can
basically save a few btes on it so that
could technically lower our memory
footprint a little bit as well keep in
mind though that if we do have a ton of
Search terms which we probably do uh
we're not going to be able to replace
all of them only the most popular ones
because a short is two bytes that
basically means that we're able to use
eight bits and uh you know you can do
the math yourself but basically that
allows us to store around 32,000 terms
or so the internet tells me I don't do
math it's
okay so now the next thing that we could
also do is lower our memory footprint
even further how can we go ahead and do
that well the idea mainly is that we can
actually use pointers right so instead
of
actually storing those terms over here
like we were before Apple blank blank
blank that's a bunch of redundant
storage what we could in theory do is
you know at every single node basically
say uh you know
popular
pointers and this is going to point
basically to the nodes that we have to
keep traversing down in order to find
our popular words and then of course you
know from this guy it would also have
its popular pointers and then we would
keep following that chain down so it
would effectively be a depth first
search but just following the popular
pointers now keep in mind that even
though this is going to save us a decent
amount of memory the main issue here is
that uh basically now we have to
Traverse more of the tree every single
time that we want to get our top
suggestions and that could potentially
take a little bit more time we want to
keep our read latencies as low as
possible and as long as we can keep our
memory footprint low enough that we can
get this thing with on a client device
that should be good enough now keep in
mind that even though I abstracted this
thing away as like a popular pointers
list where it's redundant that might
take more space as well you could even
basically for our like you know we we're
going to have an edges list on each node
right you could also store an extra bit
with each Edge basically saying whether
or not it is a popular Edge or whatnot
but uh again that's kind of
implementation details you can go think
about how to micro optimize this thing
all day I just wanted to mention that
briefly but it's not that
important cool so let's go ahead ahead
and recap what we have actually
discussed so far so mainly we've looked
at this thing from an algorithm's
perspective right because what we really
care about is optimizing read speeds as
long as we can get all of this data that
we need onto our client device somewhat
comfortably we don't really care about
its memory footprint we just want to
make reads as fast as humanly possible
and so how can we actually do that well
for starters if we can avoid making an
RPC call over the network that's going
to be great of course I still have my
Eraser up additionally if we can store
all of our data in memory as opposed to
on disk that would be really really
great if we have to store it on disk now
we're incurring a bunch of extra IO time
and even though that's still better than
having to make a network call ideally we
would like to just keep everything in
memory next we basically want to ensure
that all of our suggestions are cached
rather than just keeping the raw word
counts on every single node and then
having to recompute them every single
time that we make a query the next
aspect of thing is that tries are going
to allow us to make make o of one reads
as opposed to O of n basically relative
to the length of our search term which
is going to be very helpful uh we're
basically using advertised time
complexity here it works out pretty
nicely and then finally if we really
wanted to we could use something like
dictionary compression or some sort of
uh bit signal per Edge that indicates
whether an edge is a popular Edge to
really reduce our memory footprint
although ideally it would be nice to
just keep things simple and store the
terms at every single note cool so what
if we actually wanted to update our try
to reflect more recent searches right
because at the end of the day I did
mention that that was a requirement here
it's great if we can preload all of our
data onto our client device but at some
point this thing's going to have to get
updated as well because the popular
terms are changing every single
day so let's look at rights and why
they're actually going to be problematic
and this is not exactly that easy so
imagine that two searches come into
arvar at the same time
so note that the count was previously 15
and the count over here was 16 16 and 16
so now all of a sudden arvar is actually
moving into the top three so it means
that not only do we have to change this
guy to 17 it also means that these
changes have to propagate all the way up
such that now arvar is more popular than
one of these
guys and now that it's more popular than
those guys even it's got to propagate
all the way up to our start node and go
ahead and cancel out apple and now all
of the it's arvar that's the most
popular so note that when we make a
single write if it turns a node into one
of the more popular ones it can actually
propagate all the way up the tree and so
as a result of that in order to avoid
some sort of raise condition or
concurrency bug this is probably going
to require us to grab locks on every
single note at minimum we're going to
need to use atomics to increment
counters to avoid race conditions while
it's true that we could maybe do some
sort of snapshotting uh at the end of
the day you would have to buffer a bunch
of these rights and of course
every single client device wants to be
as accurate as possible compared to
basically every single right that any
client is doing right we're not only
reflecting how many rights that we're
making on our client device we're
reflecting how many rights are made
literally across every single user in
the world and so it is most likely going
to be the case that a single node or in
this case our actual client is not going
to be able to put up with this right
it's simply just going to be too much
for this guy to handle it can't handle
that amount of right through put and so
we're going to have to look for a better
way and so ideally in my opinion the
best way to get this thing done is going
to be using something like a batch job
and doing all of the processing in the
background so the idea is that when a
user is going to click a word basically
we just upload it to hdfs we can do this
by sending it first through our server
then into Kafka then into Flink the
reason being that this is going to allow
us to create something like a parket
file or some other structured file that
we can put into
Hadoop and so by by doing this and
actually partitioning by term name we
can ensure that all of the similar nodes
or basically all the the similar Search
terms are going to be on the same node
in hdfs which is going to provide us
some nice data locality when we do end
up running our batch job so let's look
at the type of script or spark job that
we might end up running on htfs in order
to compute our top values for every
single prefix term now let's imagine
that we've got basically this amount of
data in HD f s right so we end up with
something like hey we've seen the search
term Apple we've seen it 16 times so the
first thing that we can do in our first
like operator or pre-processing step is
we take apple and then we convert it
into all of its prefixes so you know now
all of a sudden we have the prefix a and
we say that from a we've seen Apple 16
times from AP we've seen Apple 16 times
from AP we've seen Apple 16 times you do
that basically for every possible prefix
then the next thing thing that we're
going to do is we're going to shuffle to
Partition by the tupal of zero this way
every single entry that starts with a is
going to be on the same node that's
important every single entry that starts
with ap is going to be on the same node
that's important same thing for AP and
then the last thing that we do is
actually going to be what we already
described which is using a Min Heap to
take the top end suggestions of every
single term so the whole thing here is
that because the Min Heap is going to be
small right if n is three or it's 10 we
can keep all of this data on disk while
keeping the Min Heap itself in memory
and so basically we're just iterating
over all of these and then we're using
our Min Heap to calculate the top three
suggestions and basically you know the
latency of this thing does not have to
be super low we only need to get it run
once a day and then we can actually go
ahead and send all of this data back to
our client nodes so the idea now is
we've got all of this data in Hadoop
we're going to go ahead and send it back
to memory because all of our clients now
have to pre-populate their tries so how
can we do this well imagine our hdfs
data after running the batch job looks
something like this we've pre-computed
all our suggestions right so if a user
types A we're going to suggest them
Apple arvar Arkansas for AA it's just
going to be arvar for B it's going to be
bad boy and Bob so the idea now is that
we can effectively again use another
type of lead code problem to build up
our try so the idea here is that we're
going to Loop through these guys one at
a time using a while loop right so
current index is going to reflect
basically the index of where we are in
our hdfs data and then we're going to
start by creating a start node of the
try we are going to calculate basically
where we are in our hdfs data so in this
case it would be you know we start out
with the term a and then we say if
everything up to a lines up with our
existing current trodde so in this case
you know our trodde has no characters so
this is going to work out we basically
create a new node of our try then all of
a sudden we uh take our currently newly
created node and make it a child of our
last parent we then make our current
node equal to that node that we just
created uh we set the current node to
the node that we just created and then
we also uh increment our index by one so
now instead of handling a we're doing AA
now as you can see the same thing would
come up because AA is basically equal to
a with one extra character so we run
this whole block of code again except
eventually we're going to reach B what
happens when we get to B is that
basically the idea here is uh all of a
sudden are prefix so basically
everything up to B blah blah blah so
this is going to be
nothing uh nothing is not equal
to a a so now we have to jump back up in
our try right right now up to this point
we've got start we've got a we've got AA
and so now we're saying oh shoot we have
to jump up a step then we run this Loop
one more time we say oh shoot you know
uh B is not equal to a so now we have to
jump up one more step and then all of a
sudden
nothing is equal to
nothing and then we actually create a
new node over here called B again this
is way too in-depth for this video
totally not necessary for you to
understand this code if you find it
interesting great I kind of do so that's
really all there is to it so finally
we've kind of made our way through the
basics of this problem I think what
we've covered so far is probably how I
would build something like Auto
suggestions um you know once the the
idea here is that once we create our new
try you know this might be our new guy
we had some old guy over here and this
was the one handling our old requests
and the idea is that you know once this
guy is uh complete then we can point all
of our requests over to the new guy and
then you know garbage collect this or
something like
that and then now we've cleared up our
memory we've stored our new try we
should be good to go so again that works
when we're storing everything on a
single note except in that Google
suggestion case that I estimated the
amount of data that we need we need
about four terabytes of data and if we
need 4 terabytes of data that means
we're probably going to need at least
about 10 memory servers if not more
because at the end of the day you're
probably not getting any uh servers that
are using just memory to store data with
more than 250 6 GB of memory maybe it's
possible but at the end of the day
you're definitely not getting it with
just one server especially if we're
using commodity Hardware so as a result
we're actually going to have to figure
out how to use partitioning or sharding
or whatever you want to call it to do
this effectively so how can we get this
done of course we are going to need to
think about more read optimizations
because
now instead of just hitting your device
you have to actually go and hit a server
and the server is going to have to uh
return those results and that's all over
the network and we want to make that as
fast as humanly possible so again
another thing about the server that's
going to be interesting is this guy is
stateful the reason being that if you
recall we're actually going through a
try and going through the elements one
at a time and so the server needs to
remember hey like you were here in the
try so they only have to do one more
jump to get down
here so here are the elements that we've
kind of put together we've got this
stateful server needs to know what
characters we've typed and also we're
going to be sending a lot of requests to
that server within a short period of
time and it's going to be bidirectional
so my thinking here was that what if we
used websockets so this is going to give
us two advantages one of which is that
it supports bir directional connections
so that we can actually send you know
like hey I just typed character a and
then the server can type back hey you
might be thinking
Apple but also because we're making so
many requests in such a short period of
of time we don't have to actually resend
our request headers or our response
headers which is going to be nice for
keeping the network size of all of these
requests pretty
small so what are the challenges of
websockets well they don't really
introduce any new challenges but they do
play into the fact that if we need our
server to be stateful right because we
want to maintain a persistent connection
we actually uh want the server to know
where we were in this try before
actually making another request
then it's important that all of our
queries going to the server to give us
our Auto suggestions are going to the
same node so the question is if we want
all of our requests going to the same
node how can we actually partition our
data so that at least the majority of
the time they are going to the same node
this is going to ensure that we don't
have to constantly reestablish new
websocket connections it's also going to
ensure that you know we're you know
keeping track of where we are in the try
and we don't have to make too many jumps
throughout the try to get back to that
point so how should we partition so this
at least in my opinion is going to be
one of the rare cases where I actually
suggest using range based partitioning
as opposed to Hash range based
partitioning so range based partitioning
basically means that out of all the
things we could type in our search box
we want to partition the results such
that if we were to sort them
alphabetically all of the words that are
next to each other in that sorted order
are actually going to be on the same
note no so why is this so effective well
in this case the nice thing about it is
imagine I sorted all the A's on one node
and the B's in the other it means that
if I type
A any other letters that I type after
typing a are going to be on the same
partition and as a result it means that
basically any prefix starting with a I
only have to establish one websocket for
and you know I don't have to resend all
of those headers it's going to keep our
requests nice and compact same thing
goes for B
if everything that is between B and C is
on its own partition the second I type
the letter B I can actually establish a
websocket connection with that b
partition and then I would be just fine
and truthfully if we wanted to all that
really matters is that we take an
individual like depth first search leg
of our try and we partition on that
right so if B itself had too much data
in there I could take one of the
branches of it and I could make that its
own separate partition and that's going
to be very useful because sometimes
especially when we are doing ranged
based partitioning we may have to deal
with hotspots so the point is you know
the the partition that's has all of the
a terms in it is probably going to be a
lot more popular than the partition that
has all of the X terms on it not that
many words start with X so as a result
you know by doing this range-based
partitioning we get a lot of data
locality right because as I type one
more character I'm most likely going to
still be requesting testing the same
partition but at the same time we can
run into this hotspot issue so how can
we avoid it well uh the first and
probably lowest hanging fruit most
obvious answer is to say well if we have
all of these partitions and they're all
sorted by you know let's say the first
character why is it that we don't just
say let's make 10 replicas of the a
partition and we only need two replicas
of the X partition and that's pretty
feasible definitely possible but at the
same time you know it's possible that uh
just within a maybe all the terms
starting with AB are super duper popular
compared to everything else starting
with a we may need to even do more
granular partitioning than that so what
we should be able to do is do at least
some sort of dynamic or at minimum you
know have an easy ability to repartition
our data as we see that hot spots are
coming up so how could we actually do
this well the main idea is something
that I've discussed in my Concepts
videos when it comes to partitioning
which is basically that you create a ton
of small small fix size partitions right
so maybe they don't even necessarily
start with the first two letters but it
could even be the first C uh the first
three so it could be an a AA partition
an a a b partition an a a partition and
so we keep these nice and fixed size
which should be good keep them still
based on key range so that anything
within that a AA term is still on the
same
partition and then basically the idea is
that we can have some independent
service that we're running that's going
to monitor the load on all of these
nodes and then if we see that one
particular node is you know not having
enough load on it and the other has too
much load on it we can actually copy
over a few of the partitions from the
node with a ton of traffic to the node
with less traffic and then once we do
that we can actually go ahead and update
our zookeeper or a load balancer or
whatever it's going to be to reflect
that we made that change so now all of a
sudden you know if uh the AAC partition
is super popular we can actually copy it
to the node that was previously just
holding all of the things starting with
x
and as a result once we do that we can
now start routing over those queries
over to this x node and all of a sudden
the load should be better balanced so
this is of course going to require a
couple of websocket connections right
like maybe you get one for AA and then
all of a sudden you type c and now this
requires a new
connection but two connections is still
a lot better than making a new
connection every single time that you
type in a new letter so I think we would
still winning overall by using a
solution like
this so finally that brings me to the
noble diagram how we looking on time oh
man I went over that's okay so as I said
we are going to be discussing our type
ahead suggestion diagram so imagine
we've got our client over here the first
thing that our client would do upon
typing some amount of characters maybe
they type A the load balance is going to
assign them to the a server so this is
going to you know pick up the a
partition
and finally after doing that these two
can connect via websocket so we don't
need any
headers headers are bad we only want to
send them the first time and ideally
every single request after that is nice
and small now of course if you know I
were to type in a few more characters
maybe BC I might have to actually break
this web socket connect to a different
one make a new websocket and you know
that's a Pity but uh ideally it should
keep load relatively constant between
these things
so next the the other aspect of this is
that aside from actually getting
suggestions from our suggestion service
we also need to know that every single
time someone is clicking a particular
search term that it is eventually going
to update all of our suggestions so
those should go into some sort of load
balancer which goes into an aggregation
service which goes into Kafka which of
course we would love to Shard on our
actual search term itself so that again
if we have all of the terms Apple we
want those to be on the same node from
Hadoop so that we can easily get the
count of them that makes our life a lot
easier it means we don't have to
reshuffle one extra time so again you
know if all of our apples are over here
and all of our boys are over here and
all of our Charlie are over here that
just makes counting them and uh actually
figuring out how many times people have
clicked that term a little bit easier So
eventually we're going to compute the
frequencies of all of these guys we're
going to compute the cache suggestions
of every single
prefix a is Apple
Andy
Arkansas we're going to send it right
back over to our suggestion service our
suggestion service is going to build the
try as we saw with my little lead code
pseudo code and then of course we can
switch over to actually using that try
and now all of a sudden our requests are
fetching from the new try anyways guys I
hope that this video makes sense I know
this was a little bit more in depth than
we did it the last time around and
that's kind of part of why I wanted to
remake these videos uh anyways though my
voice is hurting I want to edit this and
get to bed and so I will leave you here
and see you guys next time